joining me now live from Mallen Texas is
Lieutenant Chris alz who's the Texas
Department of Public Safety spokesperson
Chris uh what can you tell us what do
you know about these
explosives and what could have been done
with them what could happen with them
were they not
intercepted right Laura so good evening
of course as you mentioned earli that's
very disturbing very shocking when you
see images and when you know for a fact
that now we are finding explosives as a
law enforcement agency we finding
explosives that are being left on the US
side in Texas which right there in that
picture you see for yourself border
patrol recovered that particular
explosive but also the the video you saw
that's an actual gun battle that was
taking place right across the river
which is known as uh Fronton Island
which is an island that we've been able
to occupy you know because of the
general land office through commissioner
Don Buckingham who gave us the authority
to take control of this 170 acre Island
now because of that we are able to
capture all these events that are taking
place just within a 100 yards within
several hundred yards from the island
across in Mexico which is the most
violent area along the Texas Mexico
border so now that we're there operating
247 we are capturing these gun battles
and now hear an explosives that are
being detonated right across the river
and makes it a very dangerous and
volatile situation when you know the
cartels and we know for many years the
cartels have been operating in that
specific area because they're fighting
for lucrative smuggling drug smuggling
routes and now you have explosives in
the mix that makes it more dangerous so
of course if we weren't there to capture
these types of events the American
people would not know what's taking
place and how serious these threats are
and how close these threats are to the
Border well uh I want you to listen to
the White House's response to questions
about terrorists who've been able to
infiltrate the us through the southern
border watch this is it possible that
somebody who wants to commit a terrorist
attack during a time of elevated threat
crossed the southern border into the
United States already I I couldn't
possibly answer that question Peter all
I can do is tell you that we are we have
remain Vigilant okay Chris your response
to that they're recovering makeshift
explosives they can't even say it's
possible that we're vulnerable to a
potentially a devastating terror attack
because of their
purposeful uh efforts to leave the
Border
Open Lord we know for Factor has been an
elevated threat for the past three years
because of an unsecured border and the
fact that the federal government has
shown complete neglect to protect the
American people and secure the border
that just shows how irresponsible they
are to actually acknowledge the fact
that we have problems we have a serious
threat at the border we look at back we
look back all the comments that have
been made by the federal government when
they say the border secure the border is
closed that we have done more than
anyone else to secure the Border we know
that's completely false the state of
Texas is doing more the state of Texas
is doing more than anyone else right now
Laura and that's we see that right now
firstand now if it wasn't for us
actually showing these images the
American people would not know the
threats that are taking place especially
when you take into account the number of
suspected terrorists that have been
accounted at the
border yeah they're fighting against
Texas they don't want Texas to reveal
this information because then you know
it's all exposed but Chris I have some
shocking news tonight ice says that a
Venezuelan illegal failed to disclose a
homicide conviction to border patrol
back in July and was released into the
United States with a notice to appear of
course at an ice office shocker he did
not appear but guess where they finally
arrested him living in state provided
housing on Joint Base Cape Cod Chris
that's one individual he hadn't he
hadn't committed a brutal crime but how
many others are out there in the eight
million or
so exactly great point so of course you
know that's just another individual that
was able to get by and was in the was
released to the country now take into
account the number of Goda ways 1.6 1.7
known uh million Goda ways that that
that have been reported of course the
number is much higher that's just based
off an estimation and when you have
encountered individuals that have been
on the terror watch list or cartel
members or criminal gang members from
other countries or in this case violent
individuals from other countries that
have serious criminal backgrounds and
are released to the country in the
country right now the threat is already
here and that's real shocking that's
what that's why I say that the federal
government has shown complete neglect to
acknowledge the fact that we have an
unsecured border and to this date they
still refuse to do anything to secure
the
Border Chris Americans across the
country know what's going on I hope they
take their views to The Ballot Box next
year thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else